when you begin writing your first round
are you quite detailed with it and you
pare down later or is it the reverse you
do a very sparse first draft and then
fill in details later white well i'm
tomas maier i'm the author of masters of
sex so with the book actually I wrote
about 165,000 words and I wound up
editing about 40,000 whereas out of it
so sometimes the editing process is even
more difficult than the writing process
do you share your first draft with
someone or do you wait until you're into
a second or third oh no I show it
particularly to my wife Joyce who's that
the best editor I know and then I give
it to professional editors as well and I
work as a reporter for Newsday which is
a newspaper in New York so sometimes I
will show it to friends to other loved
ones and such do you find yourself
writing at a specific time are you very
diligent with your workload in terms of
writing or do you find yourself
procrastinating and then have to sorry
we just said we lost with definitely
i'll start that again you have any
tricks of getting yourself out of
procrastination let's suppose you have a
certain time that you're writing certain
things you know you're checking facebook
and doing certain things that are
procrastinating and how do you work
around well I'm very organized and I
right at night generally speaking I work
by day as as an investigative reporter
for Newsday in New York so when I come
home after dinner I'll write until about
one or two in the morning I write a very
long reporting outline that is for
masters was about two hundred thousand
words
and from that I i right and so I'm
pretty organized about that otherwise
you wouldn't get anything done lastly
for new writers would you recommend that
they write something that really
resonates with them whether it's a
coming-of-age drama or should they write
for the market for a certain genre the
thing I don't think you could have a
right to know the market because you
never really know what the markets gonna
particularly want I thought because I
have a day job as a reporter for Newsday
I wrote what I wanted to write which is
basically about America in the 20th
century so I've written about Masters
and Johnson but I've also written about
the Kennedys the Churchill's I've
written about dr. Spock the baby doctor
and I also have one I've written a book
about the new house media empire with
and that hopefully will soon be a
television series as well so you would
advise the new writer don't try to
conform to what you think Hollywood or
the literary world wants me to go for
what known in things yeah the only way
you can be true to the reader i think is
to be true to yourself as a writer so I
think if you I think a good rule of
thumb is if it interests you and you
feel really passionate about it then
that's what you should pursue and tell
it and first of all you report it out is
as thoroughly as possible research of
this thoroughly as possible and then
write the hell out thank you thank you